>> Martha: RICH, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
RICH EDSON.
>> Bret: SHANNON BREAM IS
TRACKING OUR FOX NEWS VOTER
ANALYSIS SURVEY WITH THE LATEST
NUMBERS.
SHANNON, WHAT'S ON THE MINDS OF
VIRGINIA VOTERS.
>> Shannon: WELL, GOOD EVENING
MARTHA AND BRET.
STILL TOO SOON TO KNOW OUR
WINNER.
THE CANDIDATES HAVE A VERY SOLID
BASE OF SPORTERS.
DIG IN TO WHAT THE NUMBERS ARE
TELLING US.
WITH THE McAULIFFE'S TREATING
TRENDS THIS RACE WAS HIS TO
LOSE.
YOUNGKIN THE POLITICAL NEWCOMER
WITH BIZ SAVVY HAS SURPRISED
MANY BY MAKING THIS A VERY TIGHT
CONTEST.
HERE'S WHAT WE KNOW SO FAR FROM
FOX NEWS VOTER ANALYSIS ELECTION
SURVEY.
TAKE A LOOK AT THE STRENGTHS FOR
EACH CANDIDATE.
A MAJORITY OF VOTERS UNDER 45
YEARS OLD SUPPORT McAULIFFE.
HE HAS 5 POINT EDGE THERE.
THERE IS EVEN STRONGER SUPPORT
FOR McAULIFFE AMONG WOMEN
UNDER THE AGE OF 45 GIVING HIM A
26-POINT LEAD.
THE MIDDLE GROUND MODERATES GIVE
McAULIFFE SIMILAR LEAD 25
POINTS THERE.
BLACK VOTERS GO SOLIDLY FOR
DEMOCRAT AND LARGE MAJORITY
SUPPORT McAULIFFE GIVING HIM A
HUGE 75 POINT ADVANTAGE.
IMPORTANT TO NOTE WHILE
McAULIFFE HAS ADVANTAGE AMONG
THESE GROUPS IS HE RUNNING
BEHIND THE SUPPORT LEVELS THAT
THESE SAME GROUPS HAD FOR THE
DEMOCRAT IN THE LAST GOVERNOR'S
RACE.
THAT IS HOW YOUNGKIN IS MAKING
THIS A CLOSER RACE THAN A LOT OF
PEOPLE EVER EXPECTED.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT
YOUNGKIN'S STRENGTHS.
SENIORS AGES 65 AND OLDER WERE
MORE LIKELY THAN ANY OTHER GROUP
TO VOTE EARLY AS IN PRIOR TO
ELECTION DAY NOT EARLY THIS
MORNING.
MORE THAN HALF REPORT VOTING IN
ADVANCE.
YOUNGKIN HOLDS A 14-POINT
ADVANTAGE WITH THAT GROUP.
THIS IS BIG INCREASE IN SUPPORT
FROM SENIORS SINCE THE 2017
GUBERNATORIAL CONTEST THERE IN
VIRGINIA.
ANOTHER STRONG GROUP FOR
YOUNGKIN IS WHITE MEN.
IS HE GETTING 6 IN 10 OF THEM.
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE ELECTORATE
ARE WHITE VOTERS WITHOUT A
COLLEGE DEGREE AND YOUNGKIN HAS
A STRONG 35 POINT LEAD AMONG THE
WORKING CLASS VOTERS.
FINALLY EVEN STRONGER IS
YOUNGKIN'S SUPPORT FOR WHITES
VANG GROUPS.
8 IN 10 WITH HIM.
A BATTLE GOING ON FOR FULLY ONE
HALF OF VOTERS WHO LIVE IN
SUBURBS THE HARD-FOUGHT GROUP
THAT GROUP GIVES A SLIGHT EDGE
TO McAULIFFE.
EXCITING STUFF.
MUCH MORE FOX NEW